Always two
there are no more, no less.
A master
and an apprentice.
Be mindful of the living
force, Young Padawan.
You will be tempted
by the dark side of the force
one must destroy in order to create
Buckle up.
I'm what you have here.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This'll be my Ahsoka Episode
five trailer video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references going back to Star
Wars, the Clone
Wars, Star Wars Rebels obviously
just hyping up her relationship with.
And again,
Skywalker is master and apprentice
that's why they're leaning so heavily
on the master
and apprentice relationships
across Star Wars during this trailer.
this is only the beginning.
We're only halfway through the season,
so be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
Of course, I'm
doing videos for everything.
this will all build up
to the Mandalorian season four
and then we'll have the actual
Thrawn movie.
but if the movies go well
and they do a fall trilogy,
then we'll probably see
multiple seasons of Ahsoka
in The Mandalorian that will take place
in between the Thrawn movies.
so this is really just the beginning.
and the other big thing you just saw
star Wars Twitter talking about
is that they're actually showing a soldier
episode
five in theaters because probably there's
going to be so much Anakin Skywalker.
It's going to be such a big episode
Normally in the past, when big networks
do stuff like that, like they air
episodes of television in theaters,
usually it's just the finale.
they might do this again
for the Ahsoka finale,
but they haven't said the other big thing
they're doing is tomorrow they're airing
a special episode of Ahsoka called Master
and Apprentice, a special look at Ahsoka
that might be like a Disney gallery
behind the scenes type of episode
or like the Marvel Legends episodes
where they give everyone a tutorial and
and get into Sophia's shared backstory.
I think mostly they're doing it for people
that didn't watch The Clone Wars
in Star Wars Rebels and have no idea
what their relationship is
before the big episode
with the two of them together takes place.
like, watch this tutorial
before you watch the episode
with them together so that you understand
why it's so meaningful.
They have all these scenes together
because people that didn't watch
The Clone Wars are to be like,
Why do they care so much about each other?
I don't understand.
What's the relationship here?
that's probably one of the only criticisms
of the Ahsoka series is that if you did
not watch The Clone Wars or Star Wars
Rebels, a lot of the impactful moments
just don't land quite the same way
for people who did watch the Clone Wars.
there is like a speed run version
of Ahsoka's backstory with and again
that you could watch of the Clone Wars
episodes and Star Wars Rebels.
This is pretty much what that is.
if you haven't
watched any of those episodes,
you should be able to get through
all those before next week's episode.
a lot of people also wondering
about this scene of Anakin Skywalker
because people thinking that it looks like
he has Darth Vader's lightsaber
in the world
between worlds instead of his traditional
and again, Skywalker lightsaber.
what would that mean?
Like what's
actually happening in this scene?
They did play the Darth Vader theme music
right after he recognized
and again, like,
Oh my God, it's you. And again,
but I think
what's actually going on here is that
I think he does have an it Skywalker's
lightsaber and people are just mistaken
because the way the scene is lit
so darkly, like everything in this space
in the world between worlds makes things
look very dark.
I think this is really meant
to be an action.
Skywalker's lightsaber
because he's meant to look like Anna
can did
during the events of the Clone Wars
before the events of Revenge of the Sith
when he got his scar.
That's
why he doesn't have the scar on his face.
A lot of people are wondering
about that too.
Like why is his face looks so different?
the thing about Anakin Scar
during the prequel movies is that he left
Attack of the Clones is the Padawan
then became a Jedi.
And then when Revenge of the Sith
picked up,
he just showed up in the movie
with the scar on his face.
Like, How did he get the scar?
there was actually a dark horse comic book
called Star Wars Republic number 71
that was released in 2004
before Revenge of the Sith came out.
That Canonically was supposed to explain
how he got that scar.
Right after he stopped being a Padawan
who was granted the rank of full Jedi
Knight, he has lightsaber battle
with a sarge Ventress on Coruscant.
She made Anakin think
that she was about to kill PADMÉ Amidala
before striking him across his face,
giving him the scar
Then he basically ties her up and throws
her off the top of a skyscraper.
so does that mean that the Anakin
that we're seeing here is from before
that event?
the only way that would be possible
if Ahsoka became manikins
Part one right before his fight
with the Sarge Ventress
in the only issue with
that is just the timing
of when they released all this stuff.
the Ahsoka character, was created
by George Lucas and Dave Filoni
when they were creating the Clone Wars
episodes.
But that didn't happen till 2008.
So like the Ahsoka character
didn't exist before 2008.
the comic book
story was published
in 2004, long before that.
So that's why Ahsoka isn't
in that particular comic book, even though
during that time
period between Attack of the Clones
and Revenge of the Sith, soldier
was canonically in Khan's apprentice.
So I think the idea they're saying
they're just kind of waving their hand
and saying, well,
Ahsoka would have been his Padawan.
Then before he got the scar.
A lot of people are still kind of confused
about what's happening just in general.
With Indian Skywalker's appearance.
You're like
the clothes is wearing his light saber.
It's meant to be him.
When he was Ahsoka's master
during the events of the Clone Wars.
But after Attack of the Clones.
so we're talking long
before the events of Revenge of the Sith.
Like this is meant to be
a much younger version of Anakin
long before he started having
those forged visions about PADMÉ dying.
And then sort of
getting closer to the emperor.
So we're a long ways off
from order 66 and things going
completely sideways with the Jedi Order.
the reason
why I think they played the Darth
Vader music is just to remind you
what will eventually happen to him.
Because Dave Filoni talks
about how the world between Worlds
works in sort of clarifying
what's actually happening in this moment,
This is me. Quoting what he said.
He said, It's not about time travel.
It's about a place
where everything comes together.
Everything is occurring from across time
and space at the same moment.
It's not just this place of gateways
and doorways that you go in and out of.
Even though technically Ahsoka
has gone in and out of the world
between worlds now up to two times
at least, including this time.
So yes, there are lots of doorways
to different points in time and space.
but the idea is that Anakin was pulled in
to the world between worlds.
So this is a living version of
and again, it's not a force ghost,
but it was him
much earlier in his timeline
during those events of the Clone Wars
when he was first.
So because master in the older Ahsoka
is pulled into the world between worlds.
Just as she's about to die,
she's falling off the cliff.
So the two of them are meeting here
in the same space,
even though they're from different points
in the timeline.
lot of you now asking though, how did an
Akan wind up in the war between worlds?
Because we never saw him
enter it or reference it at all
during the events of the Clone Wars
or the canonical stories
or movies like Anika
never spoke of the world between worlds.
they'll probably explain
this obviously during episode five,
but my early theory
without actually seeing the episode
is that he was probably able to enter it
because of his unique connection
with the force and the force gods,
the mortise gods.
remember, he's literally
the child of the force, the chosen one.
A good example would be the Mortes
episodes of The Clone Wars,
where they all met the father, the son,
the daughter.
Mirai is also the force owl
who appeared throughout
Star Wars rebels as well,
watching over Ahsoka many different times.
All right.
You're here if
Mora.
She's an old friend.
a lot of people wondering
if we're going to see Mirai
during the events of the Ahsoka series
later in her timeline.
one of the last big times that we saw
her was when Ezra Bridger saved Ahsoka
using the world between worlds,
implying that Mirai had something to do
with Ezra being able to enter the world
between worlds Right
before he entered,
he looked at a mural of the Mortes gods.
So Mirai could be part of the reason
why both Anakin and Ahsoka
were able to enter in this moment
from different parts of the timeline,
like she could have helped save Ahsoka
by pulling her into the wall
between worlds
as she was falling off the cliff.
there are a lot of theories
about what happened to Ahsoka too,
because some people
are taking the Anakins
dialog to mean that he's
seeing her assuming that she died.
Like he thinks that they're both dead,
seeing each other in the afterlife.
but remember,
this is not meant to be false
ghost And again,
so he's also just a little bit confused
about what's happening to they're
both meant to be alive in this moment.
in per day following his explanation
of how the world between worlds works.
It's just they're two different parts
of the timeline
colliding with each other
in the same moment.
because in this place,
everything that happened
and everything that will happen
all occurs at the same time.
generally, if we're talking about Ahsoka
being on the traditional Joseph Campbell
hero's journey,
because George Lucas talked about
Joseph Campbell a lot when he was writing
the original Star Wars movies.
This would be her innermost cave scene.
really good.
Star Wars in universe comparison
with Luke Skywalker's dagobah cave scene,
his innermost cave seen in here.
Ahsoka will be tempted to tell Anakin
about his future
becoming Darth Vader or 66 in the idea
that she could change the past
and prevent that from happening
so that he's still alive and present day.
But he just got done talking to Sabine
about not doing something like that,
which Sabine also failed.
Like she gave the map to balance school
and they were able
to get to the other galaxy
and find Thrawn and Ezra Bridger.
So this is Ahsoka
supposed to be bigger than that?
Like she's
supposed to make the hard choice
and not do what she wants to do,
which is save Annick and Skywalker
from becoming Darth Vader.
I can stop Cain from dying.
You can't save your master.
And I can't save my.
she even briefly talked to Ezra Bridger
about that.
Like,
you can't save your master from dying.
Talking about Kanan.
I'll talk about that too,
because there was a really quick blink
and you'll miss it.
Kanan Live action
cameo scene during the episode. but.
Ahsoka said I also can't save my master,
even though
technically you could do it in the world
between worlds.
talking about some of the other
things are going to be paying off
during the episode.
A lot of people were thinking
that this moment here of Ahsoka
taking the map and it burning her hand
was meant to be another
Indiana Jones reference
because they kind of gave her an Indiana
Jones moment
at the beginning of the series.
Indiana Jones is George
Lucas's other big franchise.
so maybe the map was burned into a sock,
his hand like
it was during Raiders of the Lost
Ark into the Nazi's hand.
Remember that they can also use the world
between worlds for Ahsoka
to travel to the other galaxy to She would
just need to know how to get there.
I don't know though, necessarily
going to do that
because Hu Yang is waiting
on the Cetus plane in her ship,
so she might just leave the world
between worlds and go back to her ship.
but theoretically possible
to use the world between worlds
as a sort of galactic train depot
to get to the other galaxy super quickly.
A lot of people still have some baroque
theories
about who he really was
before he became a Knight sister Zombie.
He could have been the eighth brother
who was from Star Wars
rebels and died
trying to capture Maul during Twilight
The Apprentice, mostly
because their masks are very similar.
let me know in the comments.
Who do you think Merak was
when he was still alive?
But he was probably still just a
regular inquisitor that died at some point
before the events of the Ahsoka series
then was resurrected by Morgan Elspeth
as a knight sister, Zombie
the really quick blink and you'll miss it.
Live action.
CONAN Cameo scene came during the go scene
where Hera was on
board, looked at a picture of Freddie
Prinze Jr as live action.
KANAN
So they might actually have a live action
queen in flashback scene at some point.
we could also see a version of him
inside the World Between Worlds.
In that kind of a flashback scene.
Let me know in the comments
because they showed this cameo scene
of live action, Freddie
Prinze Junior as Kanan.
Do you think we'll see a bigger cameo,
the scene of him later
There was also another really quick blink
and you'll miss it.
Mandalorian Cameo scene.
And it was Brendan Wayne.
He was one of the X-Wing pilots.
He is the stunt double for Pedro Pascal
does the on screen physical performance
for the Mandalorian character.
Pedro Pascal usually just does
the voice of the character.
but the other big payoffs they need to
show in episode five will be actual point
like making to the other galaxy they find
Thrawn and maybe also Ezra Bridger.
So let me know in the comments.
Do you think we'll just see Thrawn in next
week's episode?
Will they also show us
what really happened to Ezra Bridger
Because there's a lot of stuff
we have to do, and it sounds like
most of the episode will be dedicated
to Ahsoka and Anakin Skywalker
cannot wait to see some more Skyguy
and Snips reunion scenes.
It's going to be great,
both all your predictions in the comments
below, click here for my full episode
for video and click here
for all my other Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!